rappelez-vous le propos de gérard
collomb qui lorsqu'il a quitté la place
beauvau pour transmettre les clés à
monsieur castaner parler du danger de
quartier placé entre les mains des
islamistes et des narcotrafiquants donc
ce constat il a été fait par les
services de renseignement il ya
aujourd'hui la montée de l'islamisme
dans ces quartiers et il n'y a pas de
réponse de volonté politique de s'y
opposer avec avec fermeté avec
détermination et courage pour s'opposer
à l'islamisme il faut du courage ophélie
meunier comme beaucoup de journalistes
anne ont eu parce que des notes à ces
témoins qui ont déjà du courage je pense
hamid el bahi gelé reçu la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée nationale c'est
un jeune extraordinaire un juriste qui a
dénoncé cette communautarisation à
roubaix mais malheureusement ce qui
espace à roubaix se passe dans beaucoup
d'endroits et là j'aimerais qu'il y ait
une volonté de la part du gouvernement
il n'y en a eu aucune il faut le
souligner qu'il n'ya séparatisme l'a eue
à savoir 2 me c'était de faire de ma
maison c'était une addition de petites
mesurettes sans effet le courage aurait
été de s'opposer comme l'a fait nicolas
sarkozy comme l'a fait jacques chirac à
l'avancé de l'islamisme en tout cas à la
pose de ces drapeaux de conquête que ce
qui est notamment le voile qui est un
signe de prosélytisme qui soumet la
femme à l'égal d'un objet qui serait un
objet de tentation est bien là rien n'a
été fait les instructions des manuels
macron c'était rien sur le voile j'en
veux pour preuve ce qui s'est passé dans
la loi sur le sport que de la question
du voile dans les couples ni débattront
demain soir à l'assemblée nationale le
sénat sous l'autorité de bruno
retailleau avait souhaité et c'était une
évidence que l'on puisse interdire les
signes religieux et le voile vous savez
il y avait des feux des joueuses de
football qui voulaient pratiquer leur
sport voilées sont venus manifester mais
la ministre des sports les a soutenus ce
qui est totalement scandaleux dont le
titre de la loi qui n'interdit pas le
handball et le sénat a voulu légiférer
et le gouvernement s'y est opposé comme
il s'est opposé au port du voile à
l'interdiction du port du voile pour les
fillettes comme il cet interne est
opposée à l'interdiction du burkini dans
les piscines c'est ça la réalité du
pouvoir macro né à l'absence de courage
la lâcheté face à la montée de
l'islamisme
tout le reste c'est du baratin tout le
reste ce sont des ce sont des palabres
des paroles mais les actes ils sont
extraordinairement défaillant et lâche
et c'est pour ça que nous soutenons et
je le ferai demain soir en défendant des
amendements à l'assemblée nationale une
motion de procédure nous voulons que
dans cette loi il y est très clairement
posée ce principe d'interdiction parce
que le sport ne peut pas être un lieu de
prosélytisme islamiste il faut mettre
des garde-fous il faut poser des digues
avec beaucoup plus de volonté et de
force que cela n'est fait aujourd'hui
c'est un enjeu majeur aussi pour cette
élection présidentielle ceux qui auront
le combat le courage de livrer ce combat
sans faillir sans faiblir contre
l'islamisme les slogans ne suffisent pas
les constats ne suffisent pas devenir
président de la république c'est
aujourd'hui épousé la destinée le destin
d'une france qui sombre qui décline
c'est lui donner un sens une perspective
c'est ce qu'elle fera dimanche dans son
grand meeting au zénith à paris mais en
tout cas nous posons les pierres de ce
chemin petit pierre avec chaque jour des
propositions très pertinente réaliste
hier c'était sur le logement avant-hier
sur sur la santé sur l'éducation sur la
sécurité sur l'immigration c'est un
programme global complet sérieux et il
faut que les français est bien dans
l'esprit que seule valérie pécresse pour
abattre emmanuel macron si on veut
arrêter avec ce quinquennat de
l'impuissance de l'inutilité et bien il
ya qu un choix possible parce que sur la
table y aura plusieurs bulletins de vote
qui porteront le nom d' emmanuel macron
manière mâcon qu'est ce qu'ils
souhaitent il souhaite être confrontés
marine le pen ou à eric zemmour parce
que ça le regarde ça lui garantit une
réélection confortable dans un fauteuil
eh bien il faut casser ce scénario qu'a
voulu écrire d'avancé manuel matheron
est donc le seul vote efficace utile de
redressement pour la france et celui de
valérie bègue remercie beaucoup